public charter school in the las vegas
valley prepares to welcome back
more students on campuses tomorrow 8
news now reporter kristen drummond joins
us live in the newsroom now
with more on the transition effort by
the coral academy of science
kristin sasha coral academy of science
educates more than 3 700 students
on six campuses across the las vegas
valley the public charter school started
welcoming
some elementary students a few months
ago for hybrid learning
that's now expanding to other grade
levels to help more children in person
learning at least gives us that
opportunity to target
you know those areas that the students
need most
bringing back students and buildings
most of the coral academy of science
campuses plan to expand hybrid learning
to additional elementary grade levels
starting monday
giving them that opportunity to grow
socially and emotionally and also to
increase that socialization
john utu is principal at coral academy
of science on nellis air force base
his site gets ready for second and third
graders joining the other students
we'll have k-3 students on site our
other grade levels elementary campuses
are doing some sort of mixture
of adding third grade as well our
centennial hills campus
in the northwest side of town they're
adding k-5
the public charter school offers
families a choice to continue full-time
distance education or
full blended learning that involves a
morning or
afternoon cohort five days a week with
less than
40 percent of enrollment on each campus
say that we have an early bird student
who shows up in the morning for
in-person learning their learning does
not stop
at in the middle of the day they go home
and they have
asynchronous instruction utah says
safety remains a top priority
that includes social distancing wearing
masks and
not eating lunch on campuses do students
have recess
so students do they do not have a set
recess time
only one class goes outside at a time
not
touching any of the recess equipment
changes to keep students and staff
safe we want to bring back students
utah tells me there have been few covet
cases on his campus
any exposure he tells me was outside the
building and the school immediately
implemented quarantine
procedures reporting live in the
newsroom kristen drummond 8 news now